a source tells ET Selena Gomez is 100%  the reason Justin Bieber turned his life  around  [Music]  while the two have yet to confirm their  relationship status et has learned to  the on-again off-again couple is back on  in a major way  you got a fetish from a source tells ET  that Justin's family thinks Selena is  the good influence he needs quote Selena  is 100% the reason Justin turned his  life around he notes he's lucky to have  the second chance and he's not taking it  for granted the source adds that his  transformation hasn't been hard because  he wants to change well he knows what's  at stake he would way rather spend a  quiet night in with Selena then go get  wasted and hook up with random girls  that lifestyle just doesn't appeal to  him anymore even the singer's mom is  happy about the reunion Justin's mom  loves Selena and knows they're a good  match she's always had a soft spot for  Selena  [Music]